hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
we made it to 500 000 subscribers that's
half a million people who chose to
follow this channel i just want to start
off by of course saying thank you so
much to all of you all of you who've
subscribed all of you who leave comments
who pester other youtubers and
influencers to feature me on their
channels who leave likes bought the
program all of it is massively
appreciated it's humbling and i can't
thank you enough this is literally a
dream come true for me ever since i was
a little kid i always dreamed of
becoming the next jackie chan or a
superhero or an action star and whilst
i'm not doing any of those things i've
managed to find a way to kind of embody
some of those same ideas and make it
into a real job which i just can't
believe i get to do it's so cool and the
fact that you guys watch and subscribe
and follow along is mind boggling so
yeah i can't thank you enough and i'm
just eternally grateful
with that said i thought like last time
things it was quite successful last time
i'd do another q a to celebrate this
milestone i also have you guys in the
youtube post to share some of your
questions and you guys did that so thank
you very much without further ado let's
get straight to it so the first question
coming up comes from gabrielle gonzalez
and that says hey adam do you have any
exercises you use to help you sleep
should we walk more or train differently
to induce better sleep for the night
also congrats on five hundred thousand
man it's great to see you reach this
milestone thank you very much gabrielle
and all i'll say is for sleep my number
one recommendation by far is to use cbt
that's cognitive behavioral therapy so
not physical exercise specifically
although of course that can help with
your sleep but just learning this little
bit of metacognition thinking about the
way you're thinking i've actually made a
whole video on cbt in the past it's
several years old now but it's still one
i'm proud of so check it out and you'll
learn about that there basically you
need to convince yourself to relax
rather than fretting about not getting
to sleep and this helps you to get to
sleep faster and much deeper and as
someone who used to have trouble
sleeping ever since i started using this
trick i've had no problems whatsoever so
i hope that helps lucifer fanbase who
seems to be having something of an
existential crisis says our actions are
very minuscule and tiny and have almost
a zero impact when the size of the
universe is taken in so what motivates
you to get up every day and grind what
is your motivation by the way love your
channel thank you very much
first of all i wouldn't say i really
grind i'm not a grinder i don't have
this grind mentality i spend a lot of
time chilling out lately playing elden
ring i watch really rubbish tv with my
wife and i have no regrets about doing
it the answer to your question of where
i get my impetus even in the face of my
utter insignificance
is that it's kind of like an impulse i'm
not necessarily even always working
towards a bigger goal i just have to
make these videos i can't really explain
it i love movement and i love action and
it's something that is physical as much
as emotional and i don't know why or
where it comes from but when i was a
tiny kid i loved sonic hedgehog because
he ran and jumped and collected rings
then i loved jackie chan because he did
stunts and jumped and i love fitness
because it's physical and it involves
movement i just feel compelled to work
out in these ways i feel compelled to
make these videos to the point where
i've been doing this for over 10 years
maybe 12 years by now
and it only really started making any
profit in the last few years the last
three years so i actually was doing it
just out of pure
weird impulse to do this even though it
wasn't terribly convenient i didn't
always have time and it wasn't going
anywhere but i just did it anyways and
it's awesome that's become my job
because now i get to get paid for doing
the thing that i most love to do and i'm
most passionate about and that's why to
me it's so awesome and mind-blowing that
all of you watch and follow because i'm
just having a blast doing this thing
that i enjoy and
it's taken off which is wonderful
i can't really pronounce this one it's a
yng h-u-c-h so
it says have you got any short or
long-term injuries and how do you deal
with them and do all the different
exercises that you do and the answer to
that is yes i have
lots of short and long-term injuries as
i talked about in the previous q a i
completely broke my wrist in half so
that's a long-term injury i also break
my ankle as i talked about recently in
my ankle training video a tendon
actually pulled a bit of bone away from
the rest of the bone it didn't
completely detach but it like cracked
and came out a little bit which
obviously was a problem um i have had
tennis elbow recently i've had jumper's
knee recently fortunately that actually
provides an impetus for my training and
it helps me to become a better coach
because i learn why it happened and how
to prevent it happening in future and
how to fix it if any of you have watched
my video on my recovery protocol then
you'll know that i think a lot of these
injuries that we assume are lifelong can
actually be healed with the right
exercise and training and it's when we
stop completely to protect the injury
but often they get worse and we develop
compensatory movement patterns i've
cured the tennis elbow i've cured the
jumper's knee my back very rarely goes
out anymore if at all i might fix that
permanently so it's not about stopping
training it's about finding ways to work
around the injury and work with the
injury and gently bring it back into
movements not force it not so that it
hurts but just to keep it moving keep
the blood flowing there prevent it from
seizing up keep the motor patterns as
they should be avoid you know tension in
other areas and if you do that then you
stand the best chance of recovery and
now i'm over here and i've got a brand
new phone which is cool also
a coffee now and i have another question
from someone else with a random jumble
of letters for a name that i can't read
saying what are some of your personal
training goals what are you working
towards at the moment and i've got a
bunch so if i had to pick one as my main
one at the moment i'm really still
working on my handstand i just enjoy
handstands so much and it's something
that i think can unlock a lot of other
cool movements and it teaches a lot in
itself so i can hold a handstand pretty
well for you know a good minute but i
don't always get into the position where
i can get into that so you know it's
like one in every four handstand
attempts goes quite well so i'd like to
be able to do that more reliably because
i like to be able to get into it more
gracefully and i want to be able to do
more handstand push-ups i can do about
two before i fall over sometimes just
one so yeah i want to work on that that
in turn means working on my shoulder
mobility which still could use improving
so i can get a bit straighter a bit more
core strength and proprioception so yeah
it's a great journey as a handstand and
that's why i recommend anyone to work on
that there are plenty others though i
also want to improve my jump height in
particular that's something i'm focusing
on at the moment running speed i'm aware
i need to improve my sprint techniques
that's something i'll be looking at more
soon i've been doing a lot of jabs and
crosses lately i'm still working on
trying to improve my martial arts form a
lot of people say why are you only
jabbing and crossing when you're hitting
the bag that's just because i'm drilling
those movements over and over again
until i get them you know how i want
them but i'm starting to get the point
where i want to start incorporating
kicks again not just because kicking in
itself is cool but because it you know
transfers to so many other things
mobility explosiveness and balance all
that good stuff and again it's just a
lot of fun i think everyone can benefit
from kicking and generally balancing on
one leg and swinging their other leg
around i'm working on mobility in
general particularly i'd like to start
working towards middle splits not
necessarily to get the splits but just a
little bit more mobility in that area
and at the same time i want to maintain
and build on my strength it'd be awesome
if i could get back up to 150 kilograms
in the bench press that's necessarily a
huge focus of mine i don't want to do it
by doing lots of bench press just like
to keep working on my strength and then
see that transfer across hopefully but
we'll see how that goes and tyson g says
what are some of your favorite
recommended resources for fitness
content youtube channels books etc i'll
do a video on the books in future but
just to answer the question about
youtubers my favorite youtube resources
i watch a lot of athlean x i think he's
just straight up one of the best
resources in terms of you know good
information there's no drama with jeff
cavaliere he gets straight to the point
i enjoy his interactions with um jesse
when it comes to biomechanics he's one
of the best guys to look at he's just an
absolute pro and sometimes i have dreams
that he's my dad so that's not weird
and of course jc santana and the
institute of human performance which are
two different youtube channels but they
come as a package i
love jc i think he's one of the
luminaries of functional training
everything he says is challenging but
makes perfect sense makes you
re-evaluate your training which i think
is just so valuable highly highly
recommended i obviously also really like
jax blade's channel he's very similar to
me in terms of the type of content that
we cover we like superhero inspired
training but i think as well more than
that we both also really like training
that's fun we like to try and make sure
nobody hurts themselves at the same time
and we both like combining different
training styles with mobility and things
obviously i've got to give a shout out
to james linker from shredded sports
science not only because he's been
incredibly kind about my channel but
also because he is another one who
genuinely has tons of decent information
and
just he's diligent when it comes to
researching that
if you want a no bs review of a
supplement or something like that he's
someone who's very straight up and
honest so i highly recommend his channel
for that kind of research
obviously i love grant stevens channel
he's a regular collaborator with me we
have the same appreciation for action
films and that kind of visual style but
he also is just the don when it comes to
his speed and technique and he's great
teachers i also watch alpha destiny i
like that he has so many out there ideas
when it comes to training he's
experimenting with different things all
the time also he is a physical specimen
the one finger pull-ups he does the huge
amounts of weight you push up the
gigantic
rep sets he does for push-ups and things
just incredible when it comes to
kettlebells and club bells i've got to
give a shout-out to mark wildman i watch
his channel an awful lot you know he's
just again an expert in his field and he
gives so many useful pieces of advice i
highly recommend it when it comes to
calisthenics i love fitness faqs i love
tom merrick um sign monster strength
hampton from hybrid calisthenics all of
these are fantastic resources and
another one i really like is strength
side and i also really like saturno
movement and when some people say like
adam you can do some cool moves i'm like
check out those guys uh they can do some
cool moves and all of them go really
in-depth into how things work and you
know the little tips for improving your
posture or ben patrick knees over toes
guys it's almost disingenuous to
describe him as a youtube channel he's
more of a phenomenon a movement and i
just think he's fantastic i always
recommend his ideas on this channel
because
i mean they're thinking outside the box
but the proof is in the pudding very
much i also really like squat university
i think that's another fantastic
resource one i highly recommend and they
have tons of advice on how to improve
your squat but also just movement in
general and another collaborator i
really love liam ellis's parkour channel
i highly recommend it he does a lot of
shorts at the moment on mobility which
is fantastic and a lot of um i think he
calls him think tank thursdays where he
talks about the philosophy and movement
behind parkour so i recommend checking
him out as well feel like i'm forgetting
people so very sorry if i didn't mention
you but yeah i watch a lot of fitness
youtube and i really think there's
something to be learned from every
channel even if you maybe think they
come across as you know not your kind of
person there's almost always something
you can take from there janice horster
said i know it's not your primary goal
but it'd be very interesting nonetheless
what is your current one rep max for
squat bench and deadlift
and to that
i say yeah i actually 100 genuinely do
not know because i rarely go to the gym
anymore when i do i don't have a spotter
and i've usually got a list of things i
want to accomplish i can do 125 on the
bench press this is kilograms for you
know a good four or five repetitions so
i can probably do about 140 kilograms as
my one rep max i would say the best i
ever did was just over 150 kilograms so
that's a kind of ballpark figure but i
looked a bit bigger then it's funny how
much stronger you need to be to lift an
extra 10 kilograms that's why i don't
always think that you know
it pays off the amount of work you have
to put in once you get to that point in
terms of the deadlift again i've
actually never even measured my one rep
maximum on the deadlift however i know
that i find lifting 100 kilograms off
the ground pretty easy and i have lifted
over 150 kilograms so i probably put my
one rep max something like 170 180
kilograms as for the squat i know i'm
pretty useless in this area i don't
particularly like squatting it doesn't
feel like a natural movement to me i
like squatting i don't like squatting
with a whole load of weight on my back i
much prefer goblet squats squat jumps
that kind of thing or even just getting
into a resting squat i don't think i can
squat that much more than i can bench
which is embarrassing and all wrong
maybe about 150 so this is another area
that i need to focus on and build
towards i'm aware
but you know i'm of the opinion that if
the exercise doesn't speak to you you
don't need to necessarily bang your head
against the wall keep doing it for ages
i felt like a fraud like i had this
pressure to do the big three lifts a lot
then i realized you know there are
plenty of other ways to get all those
same benefits and
you know squatting was all you needed to
be a super faster and a super high
jumper well then all these people in the
gym who can squat a lot would be pro
athletes and it just doesn't quite work
like that so
that's a takeaway is don't feel any
pressure to do any movement that doesn't
massively speak to you if you can find
an alternative way to do it that's
perfectly good
kalmer says my dream is to start a
youtube channel like yours what is your
main tip to achieve this congrats on
half a million so excited for all the
content you'll be producing also could
you maybe even make a video on the stuff
that you do to make your videos maybe a
day in the life or something i'd love to
do that again in future i've done for a
long time and it's quite interesting now
i think the behind the scenes stuff my
biggest tip for someone who wants to be
successful on youtube not that i think
i'm you know particularly the person to
ask since it took me an awful long time
to get to this point but i will say that
the most important thing is just
consistency it's very much like training
in this regard like you can talk about
working out and you can read all the
books and things but
it's never going to be just doing the
workout you know every day or in this
case
filming a video and putting it out once
a week if you just do that you'll get
better over time it's not only about the
fact that you gradually collect
subscribers it's also the fact that
you're learning you're improving you get
a little bit of money coming in and that
increases but none of those things are
going to happen unless you put in the
time and work and it can be crushing at
the start because you put all this
effort into these videos no one comes
and watches it you're feeling kind of
self-conscious about it and then it's
years before you actually see any payoff
and can you really do it so i guess my
other tip is to make sure you love doing
it like say i do this not because i feel
like i have to do my job i do it because
i literally want to do it i almost can't
not do it i'm just always thinking about
getting outside and filming myself i
look at something i think that'll be
cool to do a push-up on i should do that
in my next video you know it like comes
from within and so i don't mind if it's
not doing well and you need to feel the
same way because it'll take a long time
potentially before you start to get that
feedback
and if you are feeling self-conscious
and you don't think the work is good
enough for whatever reason then that's
kind of the biggest hurdle you need to
get over you just put it out in whatever
format you can in a week if it takes you
more than a week then it's too
complicated just put it out in the
format it is if you're waiting for a
better camera don't just do it on your
phone if you're waiting to be better at
speaking then don't you'll get better by
practicing and this is like the fail
fast approach and it relates to every
aspect of business you need to be able
to put something out in a good enough
state to get the feedback to begin that
loop and so you also need a kind of job
that you can do on the side that's not
going to take up all your time for me
that was freelance writing which i did
for an awfully long time and i just put
out loads and loads of words
but yeah you need some kind of job that
has the flexibility to allow you to do
this in the evenings without necessarily
seeing that return find something you
love do it for the love and don't you
know make up excuses not to upload every
single week it needs to be every single
week the last thing i'll say is you know
do some research and find out what works
in terms of thumbnails and titles and
engagement these are all things that you
know i could do a lot better but
something i've learned recently is how
important it is to get right to the
point and to deliver value right at the
beginning of your videos value can be
anything it could be a cool shot that's
inspiring it could be a really useful
tip but if you spend the first 10
minutes of your video
welcoming people to the video and saying
how they should subscribe and saying
what you're going to be talking about in
the video then you've lost them and
youtube really wants to see engagement
so it wants to see people watching to
the end of the video so you need to hit
them fast with value and i try and make
sure that my videos have something cool
interesting or helpful like every few
minutes so that you're staying engaged
as much as possible i think that's one
of the things that i really try and do
and i believe makes a big difference
don't be that person who's like you know
they just don't get it so i'm gonna keep
doing my thing banging your head against
the wall and i was watching it you need
to find a way to make what you're saying
what you want to say interesting to the
widest audience possible and that's
something that i think i've been
developing lately and the last thing
i'll say is remember that emotion sells
and emotion is what makes people click
so i hope some of that is useful best of
luck with your youtube channel by the
way it might take a long time but it's
so worth it i highly recommend it to
anybody
stephen a says if you could only use one
piece of equipment for a year what would
you choose what about one movement for a
year that's another really good question
i think my one piece of equipment would
probably have to be dip bars because i
love advanced calisthenics you know
handstand practice and things like that
which i could do on there as well as
planche training and dips of course but
you can also do all the hanging
underneath things like bodyweight rows
which i think are really important and
really good for you etc and also it's
just a fun tool for training if i could
only do one exercise that's a difficult
one because the exercise i would choose
isn't one i'd recommend to the most
people the exercise i would choose is
push-ups i really like my fast explosive
push-ups they improve my strength
endurance they improve my core they make
more explosive and i just enjoy doing
them you can pump out a bunch anywhere
and you can really feel the benefits you
guys have heard on other videos the way
i do it i do it in a fast motion with
relatively shorter range of motion
almost a concentric only fashion so
there's minimal recovery time necessary
and i can just do them throughout the
day i love push-ups they're simple
they're fun and i think they're like the
cornerstone of my own training however
if i did that as my only form of
exercise i'd be sacrificing any kind of
balance or functionality because of
course i'd be all front heavy so what i
would recommend as one exercise that
targets the most things probably that
would be the kettlebell clean and press
the cross body kettlebell cleaning press
which i've talked about a little bit
recently or you're bending down in front
of you doing a little hip hinge and a
slight squat pulling the weight up from
one side and then to the other side
where you're going to rack it and then
pressing it overhead so you've got a
rotation which i think is really
important you've got a hip hinge but a
rotation combined with a hip hinge which
is often how we actually pick up things
in the real world you've got a sort of
curl when you're doing the kind of clean
you've got a press overhead a vertical
press you're training the shoulders and
the triceps and the pecs as well so it
kind of does almost everything there's a
little bit of lat involvement when
you're pulling it up
it's a real bang for your buck movement
as i like to say um of course you can't
do that though because i just chose the
dip bars as the only piece of equipment
so
yeah figure that one out
and yeah i think that's enough questions
for now i think this has been recording
now for
quite a long time 51 minutes that's
going to be fun to edit um i hope you
found something useful and interesting
here i'll probably do another one of
these maybe at a million or maybe 750
we'll see um how long it takes to get to
there once again i want to say a huge
thank you to all of you for all your
support um it really means the absolute
world to me
if you like the kind of training that i
talk about then you can check out my
ebook and training program down below in
the description that's super functional
training 2.0 over two hours of video
tutorial a massive ebook and a training
program designed to build multiple
aspects of your fitness and performance
all at once and just a quick update i'm
still working on the batman video for
2022. sorry it's taking so long um it's
just because i'm pouring like everything
into it i want this to be really good
this year um it's also going to be a
little bit of a 500 000 celebration in
its own right but yeah i've got some big
surprises i hope you guys are going to
really like it so so stay tuned for that
one and likewise i'm still working on
the montage of your guys training thank
you so much for sending that stuff in
the the batman stuff is just taking up
all my free time at the moment because
i'm ready like i say trying to make it
super extra good subscribe if you want
more like this hit the bell button if
you want to be notified when i upload a
new video and thank you so much for
watching guys
bye for now